[Music]
well the last times are gonna be in your
house only eg was invited into Real
Housewives of Orange County star Kelly
Dodds it just sold Corona del Mar
California home for a final tour before
she moves out but your favorite
housewives memory the problem of your
home when Vicki got stuck in my elevator
that was hilarious I could not stop
laughing afterwards what are the antics
probably the boot party where is that
boob cast where does it live um I tucked
it away it's in storage okay cold
storage Kelly also spilled on what's
still to come this season I can Tamara
we're gonna see some things happen there
hey hey
so what's up what can we expect I mean
it's like my marriage it's like one
minute's good and then go to you know
return and it's really good I can't keep
it away and but it's really really
exciting to watch I mean everything's go
down in Iceland and it's um it's it's
really really good okay
Iceland what can we expect on that trip
oh my gosh a lot of drinking I mean we
didn't eat so we drank and we kind of
look like lushes and it's you can just
to see what I sling like and how how
cool it's just a different world out
there it was fantastic to see it and
spend some quality time with the ladies
and we really just have a great time we
just have a great time and then I get
kind of get into it with Peggy at the
end unfortunately but yeah I don't
always try to like freak out
unless I'm pushed but yeah I mean it's
from here on out it just gets really
really good